two days before her new album drop
Celine Dion has dropped a music video
for the title track courage now we heard
this song a couple of months back but
now here is the clip
[Music]
goes first
[Music]
so we'll talk about the video in a
second
here's what Celine had to say but the
song I love it well I did not know that
a song like that was going to come but
when it did come it hit my soul pretty
hard because before the song came we
have received many beautiful songs and I
feel very privileged that people wrote
songs for me but when courage came it
kind of represented the whole journey
that I went through that I just
explained to you just before so courage
that song has such a meaning to
represent not only the album not only
the tour but the three years of trying
to find strength within myself among my
friends my entourage the people that I
work with through my fans as well with
their support so as Moses love the song
I love Stevie on the closest can't wait
to see in December Paulus's emotional
perfection I can touch this lovely and
she's amazing grief says what a stunner
yeah this is absolutely love it gives me
goosebumps her voice is so beautiful and
I we've heard this song yeah a couple
months ago it's very much in the
wheelhouse of Slean stuff we've heard a
couple of the other songs that yeah
might be mixing up a little bit so I'm
interested to hear this album on a whole
to see what she really does cuz you had
this song I liked the song but it's a
it's a very Celine Dion sorry slim down
song yeah but you know what it's
thinking so she's talking about
interviews that she started like to
dance like in their free time yeah in
that video like the clip that we showed
like yeah she's almost yeah can we get
into a video where she does like like
the choreography yeah I don't mean like
a like hip-hop dancing but I mean make
it fit in that video she was dancing
with a guy like doing a whole number
thing we're very close to getting a
sleeve job you know which I would love
yeah
I don't know who wouldn't but yeah I
know you're right like something just
very sort of elegant and you know
sixties French films she's like she's
never been allowed to do that with the
songs that she sings thank you very much
is the person that just you know is on
stage performing yeah yeah I think we're
getting close like it's time I think
it's time for a sleep down like some
choreography
Lindy on the last couple of years has
been in the go-for-it phase of her life
yeah I feel anyway and she and it's
awesome everything that she is you know
gone for has just been a wild success
it's so entertaining like Barbara says
it's beautiful God plays a role yeah
it's trying to survive her loss and yeah
that's but it's nice to see her moving
on a little bit too it's incredible to
see her